now here's where we really fell down I
felt like you really had no idea what
you're saying here so let me try and
help you right I've got one two three
examples of database systems actual
concrete data basic systems which the
media industry entertain mystery relies
upon
okay so here we are number one social
media databases now how are they used
you've got us you can't just say social
media cuz cuz everything social media
social medias the answer to everything
okay
what then let entertainment companies do
is generally target advertising to
specific people specific audience
demographics okay and what that does is
that increases viewership and increases
sales sometimes just one sometimes just
the other but the important thing is
that Facebook and Twitter
they get they raise awareness right and
they can get people to more people
interested in the movie or the game that
you're releasing okay so that's how
social media databases are actually used
and you had to mention some specifically
good secondly ecommerce right so when I
was told me I had you know iTunes that
kind of thing right
that requires some really sophisticated
databases to actually facilitate all the
transactions the purchases and to
analyze customer buying patterns right
cuz then you can suggest further
purchases people who bought this you
might also like blah blah blah blah blah
right now that's not just out of nowhere
that's not just randomly selected
there's massive databases making that
happen okay
so all of these are all of these
transaction databases which store all of
the purchases made by different people
who bought always if at least it's all
connected together okay this is a second
example and a third one I think people
are stretching for this but I saw it
quite frequently if you're going to make
a major video game or a big movie okay
almost certainly you're going to use
databases during your design phase or
what you actually release in the case of
a game right if you've got a game like
say call of duty or halo in essence
underneath it it's a big target
right you got all these different
characters and all these four enemy of
all these different weapon so all these
different what is it how is candy crush
what all these different kinds of point
levels for all I can think when you sell
a game you're selling a database okay
so games often are databases themselves
so we're relying on databases to earn
money because that's what people want
it's just they're connected to certain
game mechanics and rules that are
interesting